et on poursuit avec l'île Mauricette
écologiste spécialiste et même faire
marin madame Morissette bonsoir
bonsoir monsieur vous êtes à l'autre
bout vous êtes devant un autre une autre
mère devant le Pacifique avant couvert
mais revenons dans le golf que vous
connaissez évidemment jusqu'au fond je
vous montre la courbe et je sais pas une
année record oui c'est une année record
mais c'est pas ça monte sans arrêt
depuis les années 80 on est rendu à 11
degrés pour l'eau de surface là c'était
à 8,5 à 82 la question qu'on peut se
poser madame c'est jusqu'où ça va aller
et est-ce qu'on va voir à quoi des
dauphins bientôt qu'est-ce qui va
arriver
ben c'est sûr que les écosystèmes
changent puis malheureusement ce qu'on
voit dans le Saint-Laurent le
Saint-Laurent pour protéger sous une
cloche de verre là c'est la même chose
que tous les grands enjeux qu'on voyage
cette augmentation de température là et
de globale et puis oui ça vient avec des
espèces qui essaient de s'adapter à ces
températures là
leurs besoins vitaux c'est des
températures qui sont bien nichées donc
les espèces suivent les températures qui
leur sont les plus favorables et puis
oui il y a des changements beaucoup dans
les écosystèmes en lien avec ses
températures qui changent puis tout le
reste de l'écosystème qui est en train
de changer aussi rappelez-nous pour
quelles espèces c'est une très mauvaise
nouvelle puis quel autre ils se disent
mais finalement on vit bien avec ça
mais quand on fait le tour des espèces
là on se rend compte que le homard par
exemple qui est une espèce vraiment
prisée commercialement une des plus
importantes qu'on a et dans le golfe
dans l'est du pays le homard cherche
l'eau plus froide mais quand même
habitué à des os qui sont plus chaudes
que ce qu'on avait dans le golf donc
pour le homard le fait que le golf se
réchauffe ça fait en sorte que le homard
qui était peut-être plus sur la côte Est
américaine avant est en train de migrer
vers le nord et cherche l'eau qui est la
bonne température on va avoir plus de
homard qu'avant la crevette c'est un bon
baromètre de l'état de la couche de fond
donc on appelle le démercial et c'est
une crevette là ça vit dans de l'eau à 1
à 6 degrés donc là présentement l'eau
qui se réchauffe c'est ça ça suit le
déclin marqué de l'habitat de la
crevette donc il y a une diminution
géographique de la couverture de
territoire où on peut retrouver des
crevettes puis il y a aussi une baisse
de biomasse donc on voit aussi une
baisse de quota pour les pêcheurs avec
la crevette pour le crabe c'est la même
chose particulièrement vulnérable dans
les jeunes stades de vie ils ont besoin
de l'eau très très froide les crabes
pour survivre on parle de 0 à 2 degrés
et puis là les grands experts de pêche
océan Canada qui sortent le bilan annuel
nous apporte pas vraiment les bonnes
nouvelles côtés température de l'eau
puis on pense que ça pourrait dépasser
les trois degrés dans quelques années
donc c'est vraiment inquiétant pour
certaines espèces quelques espèces s'en
sortent mieux que d'autres mais je vous
dirais qu'en général c'est des grands
bouleversements dans l'écosystème qui
s'opèrent en ce moment est-ce qu'on
pourrait être pris avec d'autres
mauvaises nouvelles qui viennent avec je
sais pas on parle du taux d'acidité qui
augmente
des de la végétation qui viendrait
dérégler notre beau golf
oui ben ce qu'on voit là dans ce grand
bilan annuel des experts de la sumaurice
Lamontagne il y a un mot qui ressort
partout record de température pour
toutes les couches d'eau record de
faible couverture de glace record de
minimum d'oxygène les changements dans
les masse d'eau tout ça mais ça affecte
beaucoup de choses on parle de
température mais c'est aussi plus danger
d'érosion côtière une perte de
biodiversité il y a des espèces qui
devront partir vers d'autres habitats
l'oxygène qui qui est dans l'eau c'est
aussi un paramètre vital pour toutes les
espèces donc ça a des grands ça a des
grands effets sur beaucoup plus que la
température et la seule exception je
vous dirais dans quand on fait le grand
bilan des océans l'échelle mondiale je
vous disais tout à l'heure que c'est à
peu près la même chose la plus petite
échelle chez nous la seule exception
dans le golf quand on fait le bilan de
l'état de santé c'est la surpêche à
l'échelle globale on a un grand problème
de surpêche puis je vous dirais que ici
puis ça ça dépend plus des
[Musique]
maintenant évidemment on fait face à une
période grande période d'adaptation tant
pour les espèces de l'écosystème que
pour les communautés côtières qui
dépendent de ces ressources là ou encore
qui vivent sur le long de la côte parce
que moins de glace c'est aussi moins de
protection aux tempêtes les tempêtes qui
sont de plus en plus intenses et de plus
en plus fréquente donc tout ça ben c'est
la preuve que les changements
climatiques sont bien réels ça perd chez
nous aussi ça fait pas exception à la
règle puis les experts nous montrent
cette semaine de bonne fête de belles
façons à quel point les chiffres sont
clairs puis on peut plus faire
abstraction de ce grand concept
quand même sont un peu contents
qui nous parlait ce soir devant couverts
merci beaucoup
au revoir au